true
hello there watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mails
consultant editor Andrew Pierce and the
daily mirrors associate editor Kev
Maguire great to see both of you
um as ever let's start with the front
pages shall we and the financial times
leading with the bank of England's
extraordinary intervention to try to
head off the negative reaction of
worldwide markets to the government's
money budget here's the front page of
the Guardian their headline Banks 65
billion pound gamble to avert financial
crisis the eye describes the move as an
effort to save pensions
the star pictures the chancellor
quasi-quarting with the paper joking
that he's asking colleagues so does
anyone have a clue what I'm doing
even the express which usually supports
the government dubs today a day of
turmoil
and the bank's intervention is also the
main concern for the telegraph
the Metro hears that Liz truss's former
leadership rival the ex-chancellor Rishi
sunak won't attend the conservative
Conference next week with Insider
suggesting he wants to draw a
distinction between himself and the
prime minister
and the Miracles the PM blunder Truss
quick reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front pages
while you listen to Andrew and Kevin
let's say straight to them then
um anyone looking for chair in those
front pages might need to look away now
um Andrew the latest is uh Pension funds
being sucked into the Whirlwind of a
financial crisis post Friday
yeah now um Talk reading the ft and um
I've listened to people on sky and
elsewhere they're saying people's
pension pots were not under threat but
there was a concern that some pension
providers were going to be deeply
affected by what was going on in the
bond market in the guild market so the
bank of England had been um selling were
they selling guilts to try and reduce
inflation they had to abandon that
pretty abruptly and buy them to try and
stop the uh the run on on the market it
had the desired effect
um Sterling ended up up 1.4 and the
threat to the Pension funds has been has
receded but uh I I heard Andrew the uh
the the treasury Minister who was
wheeled out today he's he's clever and
he's highly effective but I think it's
incredulous to think that um anyone can
say that um the events of the last 24
hours 72 hours are not related to the to
the mini budget or the major Budget on
Friday if Beggars believe that he thinks
he can get away with that
um
but
um it's but it's calm it's been restored
but for how long that's the point
um the point about the in the the
interest rates now for for what for the
money which we have to borrow the
government's the interest rates the
government is paying back the national
debt on have come down today as well but
there's going to be no respite I fear
for people with mortgages because it
does look like those rates will go up uh
because the base rate is going to have
to go up again I think there's a strong
increasingly strong view that the bank
of England should have put them up
higher last week they put them up half a
percent the Fed was at 0.75 perhaps it
should have been 0.75 who knows how high
they're gonna have to go up so there's
still going to be days of potentially
uncertainty but I do hear that we're
going to hear from the prime minister
and chance of this Checker tomorrow
they're both going to do
um short interviews I don't know whether
they would scale or who they're with but
I think it's probably right that they do
show themselves because people are
beginning to say where are they we
should say that about Gordon Brown like
McCafferty the cat when there was
trouble like mccavity the Gap he used to
run away and it that you were beginning
to get the feeling hang on no prime
minister no Chancellor I think we need
to hear from one of them I think we're
now getting from both of them yes AWOL
is certainly what some conservative MPS
had told our political team at
Westminster and that was a growing
criticism my understanding is it's local
radio stations in fact in the morning
some eight of them some people concerned
that that's eight ways to misspeak and
then you check each one and see see what
the answer is anyway do they know what
they're going to say that's the question
Kevin
yeah those interviews the eight uh local
radio interviews their five uh minutes
each if they use exactly the same words
in each they'll just be reading from a
script they'll be it'll be criticized uh
for that and I think it's good some
Regional TV interviews two on on top of
it but the worrying thing and uh Andrew
uh touched on this and he doesn't
believe it were that they claim the
special Financial operation on Friday
had no Partners if they genuinely
believe that then that is terrifying
because clearly the spending and the tax
cuts which were mainly going to the uh
richest or what have spooked uh the the
markets
um so if they genuinely believe that
we're in a terrible position and if they
don't genuinely believe it they're
either misleading or lying and treating
people like fools either way that is
incredibly concerned you look at the Ft
we saw there today and it's its coverage
will be um terrific other payments will
have good report but this is the ft's a
special area normally they have a names
on their Splash by like they're on the
front page top left of the column it's
ft reporters they've got Pages after
Pages they go through I suspect by the
uh the end of the week most of us will
be uh pretty expert on guilts and yields
and that little chart there behind
quasi-cotting look at the fall on the
right hand side 30 uh guilt yields it's
a incredible uh about turn one instead
of selling debt uh to raise raise money
they're now having to spend as we see
there the bank of England intervention
spending 65 billion to buy debt to try
and Shore up uh the the economy yes one
trillion pounds is my understanding is
invested in bonds with these Pension
funds one trillion pounds so that's
that's what they were propping up today
um your paper
um The Daily Mirror blunder truss
certainly one economics professor I
heard on my way into work suggested that
actually the chancellor has to go he has
to be the sacrificial lamb no one will
trust him ever again we know he's been
speaking to Banks and so on
um you know this is all four days ahead
of the Conservative Party Conference
where presumably a number of
conservative MPS simply won't turn up
never tried to stay away that's what
that's what tends to happen they're very
disillusioned because there's only about
a third initially supported Liz truss
Rishi sunaka the former chancellor who
wasn't going himself he had more support
and he he warned of a fantasy fairy tale
economics Michael Gove former cabinet
minister uh said trust was taken a
holiday from reality well it's all it's
all turned out to be true she's done
what what far right uh think tanks
wanted to do
um believing in free markets well
they've got them in free fall now that's
what they've got they got them she was
warned not to do it wander the
consequences and she did it will she
sucker a Chancellor you would think she
might have to try and hold on to them
but we just don't know where this crisis
is is going they're not in control so
they can't they they can't get a get a
proper hand on it so anything could
happen now yes and Rishi sunak the Metro
tells us one of those uh Missing the
Tory Party Conference to give them the
the new PM all the space she needs is
the quote that they've got let lizzo in
the moment indeed well we'll wait we'll
wait for those liquor radio shows
tomorrow morning no doubt
um but Andrew can they stick by this uh
you know it wasn't that many budget
um you know the the bulk of the
expenditure was on financial help for
business and homes for the energy crisis
now that that was factored in there
wasn't it that wasn't the issue
yeah look can I just say a couple of
things here I would have I wish you soon
I wouldn't have gone to the Tory Party
Conference this week next week whether
there was a problem in the banking
system or not because he lost the
leadership uh no two MPS do not like
going to party conferences they hate
them in fact and loads of them will find
any excuse not to go and Kevin repeats
this old line again that that the budget
was all about giving money it was all
about giving money to the richest people
actually the cut in top rate of tax is
around accounts for about two billion
pounds of a giveaway that was about 150
billion because most of the money is to
freeze People's Energy bills for two
years it's also an income tax cut in the
basic rate of income tax which by the
way the labor party say they would not
stop and also it's about um canceling
the National Insurance rise and that
isn't for the super rich either so we
have to get this in perspective I do
think the the timing of the cut in the
top rate of tax was was not good good
and poor and it's a bad object but most
people argue that when you do cut the
top rate attacks in fact it generates
more revenue for the exchequer however
it's the way it looks but to say but to
but to paint that pick that statement on
Friday as all about giving money to the
rich that's ridiculous most of the money
has gone to freezing People's Energy
bills everybody's energy bills the
poorest and everyone the tax changes
have gone to the ridge now first of all
the Laffer Curve uh is now laughed out
it's totally discredited about raising
more for everybody Kevin yeah
is for everybody it's not just for the
rich it's for everybody and the natural
insurance right that is for all sorts of
middle-income owners teachers they'll be
benefiting from that you'll just keep
going on about the 45 being cut in tax
yes that is for the riches but that is a
very very small part of the tax package
and you know it you're do you're doing
what you always do when you're in
trouble and you talk in trouble Kevin
you're misrepresenting it again and
again and again you're doing it again
now that two and a half billion for the
top top rate goes to a very small timing
time you're overlooking you're
overlooking the cancellation of the
corporation tax rise which is about 18
billion which was soon at the former
chancellor who proposed it said will be
a quote big boom to the rich and large
corporations you're just ignoring all
that this is this is why we've got such
a mess now it's such chaos because
you're not grasping what you're doing
and why there has been this adverse
reaction and then you have to go without
talking about he's gonna have more tax
cuts do they have more free money well
look guys we're running over I just want
to show the eyes
yeah let's let's look forward if you
don't mind um with the eye talking about
public sector cuts to follow certainly
the news that we had here on Sky News
today that Whitehall is ordered to drop
efficiency plans to cut the deficit and
then the daily start so does anyone have
a exactly what I'm doing you know
reiterating once again the chance to
quasi-quartang will get some much needed
or has had some much needed fiscal
advice the paper says after the bank of
England was forced to step in to save
his sorry I won't use the word if you
don't mind she said reading it aloud
you can guess anyway lots will still
come including Labor's Deputy leader
offering a blistering critique on the
government back in just a moment
foreign
[Music]
watching The Press preview with me once
again Andrew Pierce and Kevin McGuire
from the male and the mirror
respectively but let's go in fact to the
Metro I think it is she says getting her
glasses on
um Angela Rayner
um you know some might say barnstorming
finished to the labor Party Conference
how did it go Kevin
yeah she got a very good reception it
was a very good knock about to be look
what's happened it was happening in the
government is a gift that is a disgrace
is is taking off an Infamous speech by
Liz Tross when she was an environment
secretary about cheese and said uh it
was a disgrace on the number of imports
but there was Bob after bar Bob called
it mystery of all the talentless uh the
clowns escape the the circus is one of
our England's green and pleasant land
then she said fracket I bet she um if
you went over that several times
foreign
[Laughter]
language between those two uh they don't
like each other do they but they they
they've managed to put on a good show
this weekend I was at Labor as was Kevin
and there's no doubt the mood amongst
labor activists is the most positive
I've felt it for years and years they
think what's happened in the last five
days it's created an open goal and they
think even kirst armor can't miss it
because he has it he has hit the corner
flag once or twice when there's been an
open goal but I think even he should be
he should score get a bit closer to the
back of the net this time yeah
he gets the big ones right actually
mainly gets them right you've got them
very well on on Johnson and partygate
and the big sepsis
okay I was just going to say it was it
wasn't it a year ago that brush Johnson
looked like he was going to get 10 years
in office but we move on because that's
what we know
um but very very quickly in 30 seconds
Andrew
um 30 seconds or 20 even if you don't
mind Elizabeth II statue not going on
the fourth pin sorry to rush you
no we don't want it on the fourth place
we wanted to have our own plint on our
own space which she doesn't have to
share with three statues of Nelson and
all the rest of it we want her to have
her own and and perhaps near her mum and
her father
um along the mouth okay that's another
campaign then is it good thank you both
very much indeed Andrew and uh Kevin
um super decebo thank you very much
indeed